Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 285. Ein klassisches Chaosradio heißt, wir nehmen uns ein schwieriges Thema, das irgendwie mit digitalen Krams zu tun hat, vor, nehmen es auseinander und versuchen es dann so zusammenzusetzen, dass man es verstehen kann, auch wenn man am Anfang noch gar keine Ahnung gehabt hat. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich bin hier der in der Position des Fragestellers. Das wird mir heute, glaube ich, sehr gut gelungen, weil hä, eine der höchsten Fragen sein wird, denn wir sprechen über europäische Digitalgesetzgebung. Und wenn man die letzten Jahre und oder Sendungen verfolgt hat, weiß man, da gibt es immer sehr viele lustige, bedrückende und seltsame Dinge, die man besprechen kann. Es geht heute um, kleiner Spoiler, EIDAS und KuWaks. Und was das ist und worüber man da sprechen kann und warum man, also meine Vermutung zumindest ist, dass vielleicht am Ende alles anzünden möchte, besprechen wir heute mit Anja Lehmann, hallo und herzlich willkommen. Du bist Professorin am Hasso-Platner-Institut für Kryptographie. Und hast einen offenen Brief unterschrieben, was heute noch eine Rolle spielen wird. Jessica Klaassen, hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hallo. Nachwuchsgruppenforscherin am Hasso-Platner-Institut. Was das genau ist, werden wir an dieser Stelle nicht erklären, aber man kann lustige Diskussionen über das Wissenschaftszeitförderungsgesetz oder umgedreht führen. Anyways, du beschäftigst dich mit Cybersecurity. Hat man noch Schmerzen, wenn man diesen Begriff im Titel führen muss? Oder ist Cyber mittlerweile in der Mitte der Gesellschaft angekommen?
Ich bin eigentlich relativ optimistisch und will da ein bestimmtes Beispiel raus. Das ist natürlich Let's Encrypt. Das ist eine Organisation, die hat ihre Wurzeln bei der IFF, also amerikanische Zivil.
Aha, amerikanische.
Ja, die hat aber auch in anderen Kontinenten mittlerweile ihre Naja, Dependenzen. Also was wir gelernt haben am letzten Jahrzehnt, ist eigentlich, dass sich sehr wohl auch in diesem Bereich, der lange als total festgezurrt und auch als eigentlich im Prinzip nur mit Geld kann man da irgendwas erreichen, dass sich da eine Menge ändern kann, dadurch, dass Let's Encrypt von Null auf wirklich weit über die Hälfte aller Zertifikate mittlerweile gesprungen ist. Also hier, man kann hier was verändern und auch mit einem relativ transparenten Gedanken. Denn ich glaube, das ist ja immer bei diesen Vertrauensketten so, das wird zwar nicht weniger komplex, aber durch Transparenz kann man zumindest denen, die sich dafür interessieren, einen Einblick ermöglichen. Und das ist eigentlich für mich der einzige Weg. Aber ich bin da optimistischer als früher durch das Beispiel von Let's Encrypt.
Ich muss aber nochmal fragen, weil das spuckt mich schon die ganze Zeit im Hinterkopf rum. Weil die, also alle anderen Zertifikatsanbieter ist, wenn du da als Webseite zum Beispiel oder als professioneller Anbieter ein Zertifikat willst, dann gehst du ja eine Handel, also eine Vertragsbeziehung an. Du musst das Zertifikat kaufen. Let's Encrypt funktioniert ja so, dass ich hingehen kann und mir das sozusagen selber erstelle. Das heißt, ich behaupte, ich bin ich. Aber das hat dann sozusagen, also Let's Encrypt zertifiziert das dann, weil ich hab's ja gesagt, aber es gibt sozusagen keinerlei Prozess. Also ist das nicht ein bisschen anders als die anderen? Und würde das das Problem lösen?
Es ist technisch sehr anders implementiert. Also du kriegst dieses Zertifikat nur, wenn du mit dem Server, der sich jetzt zum Beispiel ausgeben möchte und zertifizieren möchte, auch eine... Also das ist eine Verifizierung nicht mit dir. Du sagst, ich hab CCCDE, sondern diese Verifizierung durch Let's Encrypt findet dann direkt auf CCCDE auch statt. Und nur, wenn du die Kontrolle über diese Webseite hast, kriegst du auch das Zertifikat. Und wenn dein Angreifer eh die Kontrolle hätte, könnte der dir alles machen. Also solange du davon ausgehst, dass der Server, wo CCCDE drauf läuft, nicht kompromittiert ist, ist alles in Ordnung mit dieser Zertifikatsausstellung.
Also deine Darstellung ist eigentlich dann nicht ganz korrekt. Du kannst es dir ausstellen lassen und du musst dafür auch nichts bezahlt. Aber du musst die Hoheit haben darüber, was du zertifizieren willst. Also in dem Fall jetzt ein Beispiel CCCDE. Und dann musst du schon erstmal haben. Ansonsten, hm, dann kannst du dir natürlich ein Zertifikat ergaunern. Da musst du aber vorher mal kurz den Server von der entsprechenden Einheit übernommen haben. Also deine Anstandung war etwas unterkomplex.
Ich bin ja hier sozusagen aus Leinenperspektive da. Von daher soll man es sein, mir hat das nachgesehen.
Nee, aber du hast das schon getan. Aber du hast ja schon gemacht, oder? Du hast ja selber letztes Jahr einen Crypt-Zertifikat, oder? Na ja, dabei hast du sozusagen nur denklogisch daran nicht gedacht, dass du ja das, was du zertifizieren willst, auch unter deiner Hoheit hattest. Hattest du doch, Richter FM?
Ich krieg's jetzt gerade im Kopf nicht zusammen, warum das für mich ein Unterschied war. Aber ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich eher der Fehler, dass ich die Zertifikate institutionell gesehen habe. Also, wenn ich irgendwo ein Zertifikat kaufe für bundesdruckerei.de, wird da eine Geschäftsbeziehung eingegangen. Dann gibt es noch einen zweiten Kanal, auf dem sichergestellt wird, dass bundesdruckerei.de tatsächlich der Firma bundesdruckerei.de gehört. Während ich sozusagen, ich könnte mir aus einer Webseite machen, irgendwie kurz Punkt kommen und dann zuletzt in Krypt sagen, ich bin Konstanze Kurz und dann so. Aber tatsächlich sozusagen, das Zertifikat macht technisch ja nichts weiter, als zu sagen, die URL oder die Domain, mit der du kommunizierst, ist die Domain, mit der du kommunizierst. Aber wem diese Domain gehört, können wir dir nicht sagen.
Das ist eben genau das, wo auch Artikel 45 jetzt mehr machen möchte. Also es gibt auch verschiedene Zertifikatstypen und die einfachste Art, die eben auch letzten Crypt ausstellt, das sind Domain-Validations. Also dass man wirklich immer nur sagt, wem gehört diese Domain und wir binden jetzt einen Schlüssel an den Domainbesitzer. Ob hinter der Domainbesitzer, wenn es jetzt kurz dort kommen, schon gibt es vielleicht eine andere Seite, einfach eine andere Person, ein Personator oder eine andere Firma. Wenn ihr die URL nicht haben, kann ich die Domain kaufen und die einfach besetzen. Und es gibt sozusagen noch bessere Zertifikate, gab es auch schon vorher mit TLS, das heißt besser, Enhanced Validation, wo wirklich geschaut wird, ist die legale Entität dahinter, auch die, die tatsächlich zu der Domain gehört. Wurde vor ein paar Jahren eingestellt, das irgendwie verschieden darzustellen, das habe ich auch erst bei einem Konferenzvortrag, glaube ich, mal gehört. Das Logo konnte verschieden grün aufleuchten, je nachdem, was für ein Zertifikatstyp man im Hintergrund hat. Da eben eins, was noch zusätzlich wirklich die legale Identität überprüft hat. Wurde abgeschafft, weil es einfach zu kompliziert war und man das wirklich auch kaum eigentlich verifizieren konnte. Und das, was die EU jetzt möchte, deswegen heißen die Zertifikate eben auch anders. Diese Quarks, wo ich immer nicht merken kann, wofür es steht, die sollen eben gerade wieder diese legale Bindung bieten. Und verpflichten zum Beispiel auch Browser-Hersteller dazu, das, was sie abgeschafft haben, weil sie gesagt haben, die Leute haben es nicht verstanden und das konnte sogar für Phishing ausgenutzt werden, diese Identitätsinformation wieder darzustellen. Dass man eben wirklich überprüft hat, wen gehört denn diese Domänen. Einfach nicht nur ich bin Besitzer von der Domäne, sondern ich bin auch irgendwie die Firma, die das zu besitzen hat.
Aber das, also jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass die Umsetzung anscheinend bis jetzt gräulich war, ich finde das als Konzept jetzt nicht so doof.
Genau, auf den ersten Blick mag es irgendwie ganz gut aussehen. Und das haben auch größere Firmen, bei gewissen Banken will man das natürlich haben. Aber die Frage ist immer, wie kann man das überprüfen? Und also, was bitte? Durchs Zertifikat, aber zum Beispiel, was ist eine legale Identität? Weil es gibt, also der Name einer Firma ist ja nicht global eindeutig. Das heißt, ich kann auch eine Firma mit demselben oder ein anderes Land gehen, wo die Firma vielleicht nicht registriert ist, mir da denselben Firmennamen registrieren lassen. Hab dann wieder eine legale Bindung, aber vielleicht nicht in dem Staat oder in ein Land, wo ich eigentlich gerade kommunizieren möchte. Also auch da, es wird immer Möglichkeiten geben, das zu unterlaufen und einfach dieses, das Vortäuschen, dass man jetzt mehr Sicherheit hat, weil wir wirklich eine legale Bindung überprüft haben. Der tatsächliche Gewinn an Sicherheit ist, glaube ich, eher marginal. Weil man den auch wieder unterlaufen kann und man täuscht Vertrauen vor, indem man da jetzt ein größeres oder dickeres grünes Siegel hin baut, der aber genauso gut zu unterlaufen ist.
Also das heißt sozusagen, eure Aussage ist im Prinzip alles, wie hast du es genannt, Domain Verification? Also alles außer, also wenn man Zertifikate benutzt, sollte man sie nur für diese technische Definition, du redest gerade mit der Domain, mit der du glaubst, mit der du redest, nutzt eine alles andere, ist Stand heute, 30. November, Quatsch.
Es ist nicht Quatsch, also gerade bei Banken, die haben schon dieses bessere Zertifikat, aber der Unterschied wird mir nicht mehr dargestellt. Und das ist eben eine Sache, die jetzt einfach gefordert wird, dass wir sagen, wir brauchen jetzt wieder diese komplexeren Zertifikate. Und da einfach noch mal eine andere Tür aufgemacht wird, über die man gar nicht unbedingt reden muss, auch dass diese Informationen dargestellt werden. Es wird nur wieder die Komplexität für die Endnutzerin erhöhen. Und die werden überfordert sein, was jetzt ein grünes Siegel und ein grün umranntes Siegel bedeutet. Weil das gab halt wirklich früher diesen Unterschied.
Jetzt kommen wir von der Stelle, wo Konz hat doch gesagt, sie ist so leicht optimistisch, weil letzten Krüpp gibt's ja, aber so richtig schlauer wird sie.
So hab ich das auch nicht gesagt. Ich wollte nur sagen, das ist ein Beispiel, dass das keine unveränderbare Struktur ist, sondern dass man da Bewegung rein kriegt und auch wirklich viel Bewegung.
Aber momentan ist doch sozusagen vor allen Dingen, wir wollen den Artikel 45 nicht.
Ja, der muss weg.
Also anzünden, hattet ihr schon gesagt.
Dann kann ich ihn auch einfach rausstreichen.
Rausstreichen oder anzünden, aber was dann?
Na, es ist ja kein Zwang im Rahmen dieser EIDAS-Verordnung auch die Zertifikatstruktur unbedingt anzufassen. Das ist ja nicht unbedingt Zwang. Können einfach weg, verstehst du? Damit könnte immer noch EIDAS kommen.
Wir haben ja schon eine funktionierende Infrastruktur. Also warum sollten wir eine zweite Schatteninfrastruktur mit anderen Sicherheitsrichtlinien?
Moment mal! Also wir haben eine funktionierende Infrastruktur, aber wir haben schon gesagt, dass die Motivation, aus der Artikel 45 entstand, jetzt nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen ist. Also das heißt, wir müssten es trennen. Wenn man jetzt sozusagen nur aufs EIDAS-Gesetz kommt, dann sagt ihr Artikel 45 streichen, weil alles andere funktioniert auch ohne. Und was ich jetzt als halbwegs aufmerksamer Zuhörer sozusagen aber auch mitnehme, das mit dem Zertifikatsding ist schon ein Ding, da könnte man sich schon noch mal Gedanken drüber machen. Aber das muss man dann extra machen. Und das muss man vor allen Dingen nicht in der Form machen wie Artikel 45.
Nicht mit den Zertifikaten. Weil ich glaube, da haben wir wirklich funktionierende Lösungen. Und wenn ein EU-Land sagt, es möchte gerne selber eine Rootsale haben, kann es ja eine gründen. Es gibt ja Prozesse, die können einfach so eine Sache machen. Sie müssen sich halt an die Regeln entstanden, an die Standards halten müssen. Schauen, dass sie sicher sind und dann werden sie auch akzeptiert.
Wobei spielt ihr dafür? Also das wäre ja nicht, das gibt es ja.
Das unterliegende Problem war ja, dass einige anscheinend die Befürchtung haben, wir machen uns zu abhängig von amerikanischen Browsern und vielleicht machen die irgendwann in der Zukunft Entscheidungen, mit denen wir nicht mehr einverstanden sind. Und wenn aber das Problem ist, wir machen uns zu abhängig von amerikanischen Browsern, muss man dieses Problem lösen und nicht hintenrum noch was ranflanschen.
Also keine Gesetzgebung machen, sondern eher Technologieförderung oder was da Werkzeuge sind, um...
Ich fände es nicht verkehrt, meine Güte. Also in Europa könnte man es ja mal, wenn man das ernst meinte, mit der digitalen Souveränität tun. Sie haben auch nicht nur von den Amis Angst, sondern auch von den Chinesen. Also bitte.
Das heißt, das Zertifikazthema ist technisch geklärt. Es wird nur in der Tat momentan von geografisch konzentriert von... Also Software und Plattform sitzen halt im österreichischen Raum. Wenn man das diversifizieren wollen würde, müsste man das machen und nicht ein Gesetz machen, wo man vorschreibt, welche Zertifikate. Das ist sozusagen die Quintessenz.
Und deswegen auch das Beispiel von Constanze mit Let's Encrypt, weil das eben genau ein Schritt in die Richtung ist, sich unabhängiger zu machen.
Vielleicht sollten wir ja der Fairness sagen, nur ist ja offene Brief nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern auch europäisch durchaus in der Presse berichtet worden, ist ja auch nicht immer so selbstverständlich. Vielleicht sollten wir ja die Reaktionen wenigstens mal erwähnen.
Ich hatte dir ja vorhin angeboten, ob ich moderieren will. Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen. Du hast jetzt diesen Brief sozusagen geschrieben und ich habe jetzt verstanden, was die Quintessenz der Forderung sein soll. Was sagt denn die Politik und was sagen alle anderen?
Da gab es jetzt eben diese Trilog-Abstimmung und an dem Artikel selber hat sich nichts mehr geändert, aber es kam dieses Recital dazu.
Was ist denn das deutsche Wort? Was macht das? Das ist eine Form von Gegenüberstellung. Also sie haben, nee anders. Wir müssen mal kurz den Zeitplan sagen. Das war jetzt unmittelbar.
Jetzt ist der 30.
Genau. Und vor zwei Tagen war das in diesem ITRA-Ausschuss, das ist der Industrieausschuss. Und dann hat man vorher natürlich eine gewisse Zeit, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war am 8. November der offene Brief, um Änderungen darzustellen und zu veröffentlichen. Und das haben die irgendwie erst zum 16. November geschafft. Das heißt, das waren sehr wenige Tage, um überhaupt mal durchzusehen. Und diese Drews Reiter, das stellte die Änderung gegenüber. Und da hatten sie jetzt im Industrieausschuss leider festgestellt, da gab es ein Softwareversagen, weswegen diese Gegenüberstellung nicht so richtig war. Da fehlte irgendwas, da fehlten ganze Zeilen. Weswegen es jetzt eine Verschiebung gab wegen dieser technischen Probleme auf den 7. Dezember. Das heißt, wir wissen noch nicht.
Und da könnte sich noch was ändern dann? Also ist das nur eine Anzeige der Änderung oder könnte dann noch mal neu verhandelt werden? Streichen wir Artikel 45 doch noch.
An dem Artikel hat sich nichts geändert. Es kam eben so ein Recital hinzu. Und da wurden ein paar von unseren Bitten sozusagen auch erhört. Es wurde insbesondere gesagt, dass die Bedingungen, diese neuen Zertifikate der EU zu akzeptieren, sollen nicht dazu führen, dass die Verschlüsselung, dass die Browser in der Unterstützung ihrer Verschlüsselung irgendwie gehindert werden sollen.
Aber der Wortlaut ist identisch geblieben. Und dieses Recital ist halt wie eine Form von Hinzufügung. Und der eigentliche Artikel ist gleich.
Genau, es hat überhaupt nicht rechtlich Binden. Also sozusagen die Bedeutung von diesem Recital ist nicht klar. Und es ist auch wieder so ein bisschen misleading, weil eben gesagt wird, nur dadurch, dass ihr diese Roots hier, diese neuen Roots, C-artigen Sachen akzeptieren müsst, könnt ihr trotzdem die Verschlusselung genauso weitermachen wie bisher. Aber der Punkt ist ja einfach, dass man aufgrund von diesen Zertifikaten, die hinzukommen, potenziell mit falschen Schlüsseln verschlüsselt. Also das ist so... Man hat was hinzugefügt, ohne dass es eigentlich einen wirklich effektiven Punkt hat.
Also Artikel 45 kommt.
Nee, das können wir jetzt auch noch nicht genau sagen, weil du hast ja vorhin schon beschrieben, wir sind jetzt im Trilog. Das heißt, der ITRA Ausschuss, aber auch der Parlament und der Rat müssen sich ins Benehmen setzen. Und da wissen wir noch nicht, wie das Ergebnis sein wird. Ich glaube, aus politischen Gründen wird leider diese Streichung nicht mehr erfolgen. Aber man sollte die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben. Und wir haben noch nicht den 7. Dezember. Wir wissen noch nicht genau, wie das ausgehen wird. Wir werden vorher veröffentlichen. Na ja, dann würde ich jetzt selber sagen, was du vorhin sagtest. Also was man ja noch machen kann, ist auf jeden Fall gucken, wie wird es tatsächlich praktisch getan? Wie setzen sich die einzelnen Nationalstaaten hin und setzen sie um? Das muss man dann einfach beobachten. Da bleibt einem ja keine andere Wahl. Also was soll man machen? In den Untergrund gehen?
Nee. Also die Frage ist sozusagen zweigleisig. Ich wollte einerseits sagen, nach dem politischen Plan, also was macht man, wenn ein Gesetz verabschiedet würde, von dem man sagt, das muss angezündet werden? Und das andere ist aber auch aus Nutzer-Innen-Perspektive. Das heißt, absehbar haben wir vordergründig einen Browser, wo ich dann vielleicht lernen muss, wie ich einzelne Root-CAs ausschließe, zum Beispiel die von Ungarn.
Das wird auch nicht möglich sein. Es wird auch explizit gefordert, dass die Browser keine Möglichkeit zur Verfügung stellen, einzelne auszuschalten.
Haben wir noch nicht erwähnt.
Aber wenn man einen Browser Open Source macht?
Das wird vermutlich so die Konsequenz sein. Das ist dann sozusagen ein EU-Variant, der Browser geben wird und die nicht EU-Variante, von allen, die technisch versiert sind, oder vielleicht auch die, die kriminell sind, die man damit fangen wollte, die wäre dann einfach die nicht EU-Variante des Browsers nehmen, aber die normalen.
Okay, dann machen wir, wenn das so weit kommt, dann Hands-on-Chaos-Radio für nicht EU-Browser auf einem eigenen Rechner kompilieren. Der eigene Rechner muss er dann, anyways, damit beschäftigen wir uns, wenn es so weit ist.
Das ist aber schlimm trotzdem, weil das Problem ist ja, jetzt sagen wir, technisch versierte Leute können das ja irgendwie hinkriegen oder Kriminelle, aber für die große Masse könnte damit trotzdem die Überwachung kommen.
Man muss immer die Mobiltelefone heute mitdenken, wo die meisten Leute sehr viel weniger in der Lage sind, was zu konfigurieren. Und wo auch die Spanne an Betriebssystemen viel geringer ist. Also da ist halt nicht mehr eine große Linieungs-Community, wo du noch ran kannst, sondern du hast diese zwei Betriebssysteme, wo du nicht mehr viel machen kannst.
Aber gibt es einen Plan aus eurer, also Wissenschaft, NGO, Aktivisti-Perspektive, was man dann macht, wenn der Artikel 45 kommt?
Naja, es wird natürlich immer auch, das haben wir jetzt noch nicht besprochen, kann man sich natürlich überlegen, ob man strategisch den rechtlichen Weg beschreitet, könnte man ja immer noch mal tun. Ist ja bei Verordnungen auch so selten nicht.
Das heißt also eine Klage vor welchem Gericht dann?
Naja, das wird wahrscheinlich dann schon eher so sein, dass man auf die Nationalgesetzgebung gucken muss. Und dann in der Regel die nationalen Gerichte verweisen auf den EuGH, Europäischen Gerichtshof. Es ist ja sehr schwierig, den direkt anzusprechen. Aber ich glaube, vor allen Dingen muss man es im Blick behalten. Also wie setzen welche Länder wie um? Also nun sind natürlich in Europa die Länder nicht alle gleichwertig. Was zum Beispiel Deutschland für eine Gesetzgebung daraus machen wird und wie sie das umsetzen. Also vor allen Dingen praktisch umsetzen wird eine Rolle spielen. Mehr als gucken können wir dann wohl nicht. Es reiht sich halt ein in so eine Vielzahl an Gesetzgebungen, an der man echt sehr fundamentale Kritik üben kann, die vor allen Dingen aus der technischen Community kommt. Das ist jetzt gerade so eine Holfung. Das liegt aber auch ein bisschen daran, wo wir gerade sind in der Legislaturperiode. Weil jetzt gerade viel durchgesetzt wird, weil dann ja die Europawahlen kommen und die versuchen natürlich jetzt auch vieles noch durchzudrücken.
Gibt es eigentlich politische, also sozusagen in der EU-Politik, im Parlament sozusagen Fraktionen, also lassen sich da politische Richtungen klar machen, dass es irgendjemanden gibt, der sagt, das ist aber Quatsch, was ihr da gerade macht. Oder sind politisch gesehen eigentlich alle dafür?
Naja, das ist deshalb schwierig, weil das hier ja nicht der Ausschuss für bürgerliche Freiheiten ist oder so. Also der Innenausschuss, sondern das ist der Industrieausschuss. Da sind oft die Parlamentarier drin, die ohnehin sehr wirtschaftsfreundlich sind und ein Ohr an der Wirtschaft haben. Und weniger jetzt an den Lippen der Zivilgesellschaft hängen oder gerne die Akademie ja von vorne bis hinten lesen. Das ist ja ein Industrieausschuss, der hier federführend ist, Idre. Und insofern würde ich schon meinen... Das scheint mir auch so ein bisschen in der Reaktion. Mein Eindruck ist, dass das so ein bisschen abgetan wird, als oh, hier läuft eine Kampagne gegen uns und sich gar nicht auf die Argumente, die ja auch schriftlich dargelegt sind, in diesem offenen Brief, den wir verlinken werden, darauf es richtig eingegangen wird. Das sieht man auch, finde ich, an der unmittelbaren Reaktion. Finde das halt schade. Und dann noch dieser heimliche Vorwurf, der jetzt sozusagen an die Akademie gemacht wird, da man hätte sich da mit Google ins Bett gelegt oder mit Mozilla, die ja nun auch dieselbe Position vertreten, die sind das natürlich im Farm. Weil der letztlich, also hier bringt eine Kommilitie von Experten Argumente vor. Und man kriegt nur komische Antworten, die irgendwie an der Seite vorbei argumentieren.
Darf ich mich kurz auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, dass EU-PolitikerInnen sagen, die Wissenschaft wäre sozusagen Opfer von Lobbyismus geworden?
Nein, so direkt ist es dann doch wieder nicht.
Doch, ich glaube, da gibt es wirklich Statements, die das so direkt sagen.
So direkt? Okay, echt? Ich dachte, das wäre so hinter der Blume.
Nein, da gibt es ein paar Statements leider.
Ich meine jetzt auch durch die Blume sozusagen nur übersetzt, aber das ist schon wow. Okay, das ist, okay. Ich hatte ja ursprünglich gefragt, was war die Reaktion an der Politik? Nicht so gut haben wir gerade erfahren. Was sagt denn der Rest der Welt dazu?
Oh, profunde Desinteresse würde ich sagen. Also ich habe den Eindruck, dass das schon wieder sehr, sehr nischig ist. Also man braucht immer sehr lange, wenn man richtig so fundamentale Kritik durchbringen will. Und dafür ist der Prozess schon zu weit am Ende, glaube ich.
Und das ist auch technisch zu kompliziert, glaube ich. Also irgendwie zu erklären, wie diese Zertifikate was mit Verschlüsselung zu tun haben. Und jetzt, weil wir noch mehr vertrauenswürdige Zertifikate hinzufügen. Wie kann es denn schlimm sein? Also es ist irgendwie so ein technisch anspruchsvolles Thema. Und das gibt es eben auch gerade. Heute wurde jetzt auch nochmal so ein Dokument geleakt, wo halt wirklich auch die Komplexität so ausgenutzt wird, um ja Missinformationen zu verbreiten. Um einfach zu sagen, es wird ja nicht schlimmer, es wird ja alles besser.
Also nicht von wem geleakt, sondern sagen, wessen Dokument?
Das ging an die MEPs, also Member of European Parliament. Einfach nochmal so ein Informationsdokument. Ich weiß nicht, wer da absend ist. Ich glaube, das ist nicht rausgekommen. Aber da wurde dann so gegenübergestellt, was sind denn jetzt diese neuen qualifizierten Zertifikate? Was bedeutet das? Da wurde eben schon auf die Argumente eingegangen. Aber eben jedes Argument ist halt, das ist, sagen wir mal, misleading, als wäre noch die beste Beschreibung, die mir da einfällt.
Also es werden quasi die Kritiken komplett umgedreht. Also so ein, hey, es gab doch die folgenden Kritiken, aber das stimmt überhaupt nicht, weil. Und danach kommt eine Begründung, die sich für jemanden, der technisch nicht so tief drinsteckt, so liest, als wäre eben dieser Brief von Wissenschaftlern, Wissenschaftlerinnen falsch. Also es ist quasi so ein, das Argument kam, aber das stimmt gar nicht. Und man muss eben sich sehr, sehr, sehr tief mit der Technik beschäftigt haben, um zu wissen, wer lügt hier eigentlich wen an. Und das ist halt super schade. Also ich meine, es gibt ja genau deswegen Wissenschaftlerinnen, Wissenschaftler, die sagen, hey, das ist unsere Meinung, wir haben das unterschrieben. Und trotzdem gibt es eben irgendjemand, wir kennen den Absender halt leider nicht, der sagt so, ne, die Argumente stimmen nicht. Und alles ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, weil...
Das ist eine schwierige Situation auch für Journalisten, muss man natürlich auch sehen. Also, Adet überhaupt zu berichten, das ist jetzt nicht gerade das Sexiness weit oben.
Wir haben doch nur anderthalb Stunden gebraucht, um das grob zu verstehen.
Also, es zeigt halt so ein bisschen... Es ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt... Es ist kein gutes Beispiel, weil letztlich hat natürlich der Protest auch spät begonnen. In dem Prozess. Andererseits gab es schon sehr frühe Proteste 2021. Da war der Kommissionsvorschlag relativ frisch. Und vieles von dem, was wir heute aufgezählt haben, war da schon ein Teil der Kritik, inklusive Artikel 45, explizit, mit denselben Argumenten. Übrigens auch auf eine Weise erklärt, die man hätte verstehen können. Aber was willst du denn nun machen? Jetzt sind die Monate vergangen. Da ist natürlich jetzt Druck. Weil jetzt oder nie? Sonst kommt die Europawahl. Ich weiß nicht so recht. Ich bin mittlerweile, soweit ich sage, man muss auch den Mut haben, zu sagen, streicht es. Viele trauen sich oft nicht mehr. Die machen dann so eine... Ja, da können wir uns noch irgendwie mit abfinden.
Aber ich bin da wirklich rigoros. Gibt es jemanden außer der Politik, die ein Interesse dafür haben? Also ich frage mich jetzt gerade nochmal auf einen Brief. Die sagen auch von Google und Mozilla, also sagen auch großen Playern. Und im Fall von Google auch mit quasi unendlich Geld und Lobbymöglichkeit in Brüssel. Gab es auch irgendwie eine Industrie, die dachte so geil, europäische Zertifikate voll gut, damit machen wir viel Geld?
Genau, das ist glaube ich so ein Punkt, den wir noch gar nicht angesprochen haben. Ich glaube, da ist eben auch der größte Druck her. Weil mit Let's Encrypt wurden diese Zertifikate kostenlos.
Ja, das hat man noch nicht erwähnt. Das ist ein wichtiger, gut, dass du das nochmal gefragt hast.
Achso, das heißt sozusagen, und jetzt sehen Zertifikatsanbieter...
Die Möglichkeit eben wieder diese Extended Validation wieder einzuführen auf dem Hinterweg, zu sagen, wir müssen eben diese Identitätsprüfung machen. Es geht eben nicht alles automatisch, indem wir das nur an die Domänen binden. Und wir haben zufälligerweise schon die ganzen CAs alles vorbereitet. Und jetzt haben wir wieder unser altes Businessmodell rausgeholt.
Und wir haben eine Verpflichtung in der Verordnung, dass ganz Bereiche der Branche mitmachen müssen, also der Wirtschaftsbranche. Das ist quasi eine Gelddruckmaschine. Seien wir mal ehrlich, ohne ganz generelle EU-Kritik üben zu müssen, aber das ist halt auch nicht irgendwie... Brüssel ist nicht gerade der Mittelpunkt der Grundrechte, sondern die haben halt sehr viele Interessenträger, die sich da breit tun, und gerade im e-Trauerschuss.
Ja, schade.
Na ja, wir haben dagegen mit Informationen angekämpft.
Das ist echt... Also Chaosradios sind ja oft deprimierend, aber oft sozusagen wegen des Zustands der Welt. Und am Ende immerhin meistens noch mit der Möglichkeit Dinge anzuzünden. Aber das finde ich total faszinierend, weil das ist einerseits ist das nicht so hart, also keine Ahnung, so ein Staatstrojaner, unfassbares Übel, aber irgendwie in seiner Auswirkung auch sehr konkret. So eine Zertifikatsrouteninfrastruktur, die ist ja erstmal nichts per se Schlimmes. Also wenn das jetzt kommt, geht die Welt nicht sofort unter. Aber es ist sozusagen so eine Art slippery slope in den Weltuntergang hinein. Und trotzdem macht jemand was. Und es ist auch schon viel zu spät. Es ist mega deprimierend.
Also wir hier und die Wissenschaftler, die sich zusammengetan haben, wir machen ja.
Ja, aber es fühlt sich...
So können wir nicht enden, Markus. Das geht nicht.
Ich hatte so gute Laune in den letzten Monaten. Vielen Dank. Aber was ist denn der Lichtblick?
Es kann ja noch sein, dass am 7. Dezember doch noch alles anders kommt.
Hilft es da, wenn man jetzt seinen EU-Abgeordneten nochmal mal zitiert oder was?
Warum nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, warum nicht.
Also schreibt drüber, kontaktiert die Abgeordneten. Aber man kann auch weiterverbreiten, was andere geschrieben haben. Es gibt jetzt eine Menge kritische Presse, aber auch jenseits von der Tech-Presse, die jetzt darüber schreibt. Duet, also ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwie ein Geheimthema wird. Es gibt schon Leute, die sich damit auseinandersetzen in Deutsch, aber auch in Englisch. Also ja, beteiligt euch. Kleiner Aktivismus wird groß.
Und wenn jemand sagt, ich verstehe das aber nicht, dann gebt ihm einfach dieses Chaosradio zum Hören.
Komm, wir haben Erklärung-mäßig, Erklärbar-mäßig, oder? Waren wir doch?
Also ich traue mir das nicht zu sagen, weil wir stecken jetzt sagen, in der Sendung drin, aber liebe Hörerinnen, wenn ihr Kommentare und Feedback habt, schreibt's auf chaosradio.de dort ins Kommentarfeld. Anja, ihr scauen konnt's. Vielen lieben Dank. Es war ernüchternd, aber wenigstens gut erklärt. Und ansonsten bleibt mir nur das zu sagen, was mir immer noch am Ende übrig bleibt. Der einzige Stein, an dem wir uns festhalten können. Lasst euch nicht überwachen. Wichtiger denn je heute und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Back-ups.